when you do your taxes the IRS doesn't
send you a receipt so just where does
all that money go meet Jane Jay is 28
years old and makes fifty one thousand
nine hundred and fifteen dollars per
year
Jane is single and has no children so
she pays Uncle Sam about eight thousand
seven hundred and seventy two dollars so
what happens to her tax money
well each state is different so let's
just focus on federal taxes and we're
not including Social Security and
Medicare because those are paid
separately here's the breakdown the
biggest amount two thousand five hundred
and sixteen dollars goes to health
programs including Medicaid in
children's health
then there's the military 2226 of jane's
tax dollars go to paying for our
national defense and the big chunk is
dedicated to paying off the interest on
the national debt when it comes to
everything else the numbers get a lot
smaller there's unemployment and labor
veteran's benefits food and agriculture
education and running the government
then there's Housing and Community
Programs energy in the environment
International Affairs and transportation
finally a mere 96 dollars goes towards
scientific research which includes NASA
would you change how your tax dollars
are you